[Applause]
[Music]
we are here on the seat
of the patriot awards in
in the good hollywood hollywood florida
you can stream the whole thing right
after the show it's on foxnation.com we
recommend it
but first good evening and welcome to
tucker carlson tonight so there's
difference between lying in propaganda
and it's worth knowing what it is
all propaganda is lying but not all
lying is propaganda so what's the
difference between the two here's what
lying is think about think about the
moments in your own life when you have
lied
most of the time you do it because you
have done something that you're ashamed
of and you're hoping nobody's going to
find out when you're caught as
inevitably you are caught you shade the
truth
so someone says to you you're drunk and
you say no i'm not i've only had three
beers but actually you had eight beers
you're lying that's what lying is
propaganda is very different from that
propaganda is not a shading of the truth
propaganda is a complete inversion of
the truth you're drunk somebody tells
you no i'm not you reply
you're the one who's drunk you've had
eight beers it's shameful and i'm
disgusted by your drunkenness
that's what propaganda looks like it's
the mirror image of reality it's the
exact opposite of the truth and it is
always delivered with ferocious
aggression
propaganda tends to bewilder people to
confuse them when they first hear it
it's so completely and obviously untrue
what is this you think and yet for that
very reason because it's so ridiculous
so absurd propaganda tends to be
effective
people assume that lies that bold have
got to be true something about the human
brain reaches that conclusion and always
has and that's why propaganda has always
been a feature of society especially now
it's why we're now swimming in
propaganda january 6 was an armed
insurrection they screamed russia is the
real threat the 2020 election was
perfectly fair covet is more dangerous
than opioids no really it is it's all
true
we can give you countless examples of
this in action and you would recognize
every one of them but here's one from
today's headlines kyle rittenhouse is a
white supremacist
now you're hearing that claim constantly
for media figures and from politicians
as a factual matter in case anybody
cares that is a lie
there's no evidence whatsoever that kyle
rittenhouse is a white supremacist
whatever that term is supposed to mean
there is precisely no racial angle at
all to this story none
of the four people directly involved in
the kyle rittenhouse shootings all four
of them were white
so you might not like kyle ridden house
but if you're an honest person you would
have to concede that racism had nothing
to do with what he did how could it why
would a white supremacist shoot white
people it doesn't even make sense
but that has not stopped them from
telling you the opposite or even slowed
them down
here's joe biden just two days after the
shootings in kenosha writing the first
draft of what turned out to be a long
propaganda campaign
he has espoused some views he's part of
a youth police group he was holding a
long gun he was out and about nobody
restrained him um
what are your concerns about the
involvement of
others perhaps he but others who are
white militia people stirring this
trouble
oh i'm very concerned about it again you
saw what got me involved in this race
and i hadn't planned on running in the
first place was what happened in
charlottesville the same kind of appeal
to
these guys don't use a dog whistle they
use a bullhorn
they use a bullhorn and there's a 17
year old young man
i don't know anything about them all i
know is that there's some reporting
about a connection to a militia in
illinois
so really you should save that tape it
is a textbook example of what's going on
of what they do
notice the framing of that conversation
so the propagandist from nbc news
doesn't come out and call kyle
rittenhouse a white supremacist she
can't do that the shootings just
happened hours before the facts are too
fresh there was no evidence that kyle
rittenhouse had ugly racial views much
less that he was motivated to shoot
people because of those views and
everyone who's paying attention at the
time knew that very well
so instead of making the claim directly
the liar from nbc news stealthily
broadens the question
are you concerned about others who are
white militia people
but wait a second what other white
militia people where are these people
what are you talking about exactly
but the liar from nbc news never tells
us what she's talking about that's not
the point
she has given her candidate joe biden
the opportunity to take it from there
which of course he immediately does
that's the point of the setup and then
biden goes on to invoke the protests in
charlottesville virginia from years
before which have precisely nothing to
do with anything that happened in
kenosha wisconsin in the summer of 2020
but they didn't need to be connected
factually the point was obvious everyone
watching understood the point the point
was
kyle rittenhouse is a dangerous racist
and by the way anyone who would defend
kyle written house probably a dangerous
racist too maybe one of those white
militia people
you see how that works it works by
indirection and stealth and dishonesty
but of course you see it because you see
it every day because it never ended
they're still telling the same thing now
and because they've never stopped
repeating that lie a lot of people now
assume that it must be true kyle written
house he's a white supremacist right
many people think that why wouldn't they
so why have they been doing this for 15
months well now it's obvious if kyle
rittenhouse wasn't actually what he was
which was a 17 year old lifeguard who
came to kenosha to clean antifa graffiti
off the walls of school if he was
something else entirely if he was an
armed bigot a member of some kind of
white supremacist militia then the trial
looks very very different
if that's true then this trial is no
longer about the principle of
self-defense it's only about whether
kyle rittenhouse's rifle was legal under
wisconsin law no no it's not something
much bigger than that
if their lies are true it means this
trial is about whether black people can
continue to live in the united states
without being fear
in fear of being murdered by white
supremacist militiamen like kyle
rittenhouse
and by the way after much repetition at
this point many americans believe that's
exactly what the trial is about and they
believe it because they keep hearing it
on msnbc
there are only so many acceptable losses
that white supremacy is willing to
accept so if derek chovin is going to
jail you had best believe that ahmad
arbury's murderers people like kyle
rittenhouse are going to be defended
with all that this culture has because
they have to make sure that the message
is sent that white when white men will
continue to control these systems and
that the rest of us should be living in
fear
if kyle rittenhouse is acquitted quote
the rest of us should be living in fear
now why would he be living in fear
because kyle rittenhouse might go on to
shoot other convicted child rapists and
violent criminals who are actually
trying to murder him
that's the threat how afraid should the
rest of us be of that
once again that claim doesn't even make
sense but it doesn't need to
the fact that it's nonsensical does not
diminish in any way the emotional power
of those words the rest of us should be
living in fear imagine hearing that on
live television from someone you're
supposed to trust would scare the hell
out of you yes it would and of course
that's the point of saying it
but there's another point too and that
point is to subvert our system of
justice
american justice is based on the
principle of equality the principle that
all of us are equal under the law no
matter what we look like no matter who
our parents were no matter where we came
from that's called equality and until
very recently our leaders were proud to
offer it
equity is something very very different
in fact it's the opposite of equality
if you think equity is the point of the
justice system then you don't care about
the details you're not interested in the
evidence you're not interested in who is
actually guilty or innocent before the
law
what you care about instead is the
appearance of the defendants the
identity of the people who are convicted
and acquitted
according to the principles of equity
how you were born determines whether or
not you are guilty that's equity
and it's not a fringe theory anymore
according to joe biden himself equity is
the organizing principle of this white
house he said so the day he was
inaugurated
but in order to replace equality in our
justice system and every other
institution with equity
that means you have to tear down the
system we currently have and have used
for the last 250 years that's not easy
it's a big assignment how do you do it
well in the justice system there's no
faster way to tear it down than by
calling judges racist which needless to
say is exactly what they're doing now
he has made a series of decisions each
one perhaps may be individually
defensible but in totality
lead to the impression of a biased
racist judge with his trump rally cell
phone
that is trying to get rid of the house
uh a walk
the racist judge
so that's a very heavy thing to say
about anyone particularly a sitting
judge in the middle of a murder trial so
the question is is the judge actually a
racist and the answer as you know by now
is that no there's no evidence of that
at all and the man who just claimed the
judge was racist knows there's no
evidence of it the manager's claimed it
by the way to harvard law school he's
not stupid he knows what the facts are
he just doesn't care what the facts are
whatever it takes
so this way of looking at the world
intentionally denying reality for the
sake of a desired outcome is often
called post-modernism
but that's not quite right in fact this
is pre-modern
this is an instinct older than
civilization itself and in fact a
challenge to civilization itself this is
the kind of thinking that leads to
tribalism tribalism is the belief that
my team is always right and your team is
barely human
tribalism has been around for as long as
people have been around it's never gone
away it just lurks beneath the surface
of societies all societies one of the
main goals of any civilization is to
suppress tribalism so that we can live
together without killing one another
so you should be concerned when it
reemerges in public and boy has it watch
this
it's car written house trial
it reminded a lot of people of something
something i just can't remember what it
was oh
the brett kavanaugh hearings in which
brett kavanaugh who had been accused by
a high school friend of committing
sexual abuse of her
cried his way through
the hearings to make him a permanent
member
and associate justice of the united
states supreme court
and his tears turned out to be more
powerful than the tears of christine
blasey ford which were the tears of an
alleged victim
but in america there's a thing
about both white vigilantism
and white tears
particularly
male white tears
so that is a currently employed msnbc
anchor another harvard graduate not an
employee of radio rwanda
and that person is telling us what she
really thinks in a tick tock video white
tears
she mocks the very idea people that evil
can't cry they don't have human emotions
because they're not really human you
don't have to care about them they don't
qualify for your compassion you can
laugh as they weep and feel good about
it
you often hear the word dehumanize what
does it mean that's what it looks like
so you wonder how long this can go on
our country before something really
important breaks hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else